il y a trois semaines. Notre
envoyé spécial à Kherson, Marie-
Ève Bédard.
- Kherson, cité héroïque.
Les affichuiuiui le proclament
tapissent la route qui mène
au centre de la ville qui a été
occupée par la Russie pendant
neuf mois.
Mais si beaucout t t résisté
à ces mois d'occupation russe,
aujourd'hui, ils partent.
L'immense joie de Tetyana
quand elle a vu arriver
les soldukukukrainiens tant
attendus fait place à la peur.
"Les tirs sont intenses
dans notre quartier, dit-elle.
La nuit dernière, ils ont tiré
sans arrêt. Les obus sont tombés
tout près, c'est pour ça
qu'on doit partir."
Elltetetete sans son beau-fils,
Volodymyr.
"Il ne faut pas laisser que
des vieillards dans la ville",
ilililil. Mais il n'en est
pas moins terrorisé
par les bombardements.
- Qui n'a pas peur...
est mort.
Tout le monde a peur.
- Kherson en avait été plutôt
préservée, mais c'est un nouvel
enfer qui enveloppe la ville
depuis la déroute de la Russie.
Depuis la rive orientale du
Dniepr où ils sont retranchés,
ces soldats pilonnent Kherson
sans merci.
Pacha compreneseseseses risques
que prennent chacun de ceux
qui s'accrochent à leurs terres.
Il allait à vélo quand une pluie
de tirs atatatatattue
tout autour de lui.
"Ils visent les civils,
ils savent bien où ntststststs
sont postés, raconte le jeune
homme. Mais ils ne les ciblent
pas. Ils tirent sur les civils
comme ça."
Victor, lui rentrait à peine à
la maison quand il a été sonné
par une explosion.
"F m m m m m mort, ça reste miex
que de vivre sous le joug des
soldats de Vladimir Poutine",
dit-il.
Ils allaient de maison
en maison, ils volaient,
ils tuaient, se rappelle-t-il,
et ils emmenaient les gens
dans les sou
Les sous-sols. C'est un mot
qui est devenu synonyme de
torture en Ukraine, partoutoù l.
"J'ai enduré la torture physique
dit Leonid, mais ce n'est rien
comparativement à ce que
nos patriotes ont dû endurer."
Leonid Remiga est dire
des trois hôpitaux de la ville.
Un résistant, lui aussi, qui a
défié les ordres de la nouvelle
administration r
longtemps qu'il a pu.
De mars à septembre, il a dirigé
son petit hôpital en y cachant
les soldat b b b b b b blessés.
Ils étaient enregistrés comme
de simples civils. Il a aussi
déjoué la volonté de l'occupant
de tononononononon établissement
en hôpital militaire pour
l'armée de Vladimir Poutine.
Quand les soldats sont arrivés,
il avait mis en scène une
éclosion majeure de COVID,
combinaison de protection
et affichee à l'appui. Mais
les Russes en ont finalement eu
assez de son entêtement et sont
venus l'arrêter. C'est en prisoe
leur cruauté.
Ils donnaient des électrochocs.
Dans le jargon de la prison,
ils disaient qu'ils passaient
un coup de fil à Zelensky.
Qu'est-ce que c'est?
C'est une électrode qui est
placée sur l'oreille et
une autre sur le scrotum.
Puis, ils déclenchent le courant
électrique. S'il est un héros,
alors c'est un héros bien
ordinaire à Kherson, dit Leonid,
rappelant que sa ville à d'abord
tenu tête aux chars russes.
Des foules de manifestants ont
terrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrer la route,
montant sur les chars, en criant
aux Russes de rentrer chez eux.
Les images de cette
démonstration de bravoure ontemr
le sentiment patriotique
des Ukrainiens. Leonid Remiga
y a puisé la force de résistera.
Le directeur de l'hôpital
ne bronc
des explosions.
"Les Russes se vengent", dit-il.
Depuis le retrait des Russes,
plus de 30 personnes sont mortes
sous les tirs de l'armée russe.
Ils meurent à la maison,
en circulant dans la rue,
à la recherche d'eau, au hasard
d'un quotidien accaparé par
la survie.
À ces tirs constants s'ajoute
une arme redoutable dans
l'arsenal de la Ru
l'hiver, le froid.
En se retirant, ils ont détruit
la majorité des infrastructures.
Et si on travaille d'arrache-réé
et l'eau potable, la très vaste
majorité des habitations de ceux
qui restent sont sans chauffage.
La vie dans la cité des héros
est épuisante. On vient chercher
de l'eau, on se rue sur la d d t
de quoi se défendre du froid.
Ce camion est rempli de
couvertures et autres donsyéyéy.
Un peu partout en ville,
de grandes tentes chauffées
permette
recharger leur téléphone,
de se brancher sur un monde dont
ils étaient coupés, de reprendre
unmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbmbat
de chaque instant, dont
on s'accommode. La liberté,
dit-on ici, vaut bien toutesouo.
Ici Marie-Ève Bédard,
Radio-Can